ever since i got my hands on the 13 pro
max i've been using it every single day
and i'm gonna be sharing my thoughts on
which features actually matter to me
first up we have the changes that matter
to me the least like one terabyte iphone
model dual e sim feature pro res
recording format and photographic styles
talking a little bit about the cameras
much less likely to have blown out
clouds in the background and sun flaring
isn't nearly as bad of a problem as it
was last year i've never been more happy
with the camera performance and when it
comes to 4k video recording across any
of the lenses it's the best in the
business i've only witnessed the display
dim a couple of times compared to
literally a daily basis with the 12 pro
max i no longer have to even think about
my battery life because it can literally
last a day and a half this 13 pro max
feels more snappy than any iphone i've
ever had solely because of once when it
hurts promotion especially for scrolling
through content like twitter